omicron cases are surging around the
world and france is the latest country
to hit a new record
more than 330 000 new cases on wednesday
that's 60 000 more than the previous
record just a day earlier almost three
quarters of icu beds across the country
are now occupied by cobit 19 patients
and clearly losing patience french
president emmanuel macron had some salty
words for anyone still unvaccinated
another record rising cases as omicron
sweeps through europe
332 000 covert 19 infections in france
in one day alone
we have to prepare for it that's
supersonic rise in new cases will keep
going for several days maybe weeks
there's so far no visible change in the
trend
nine in ten french adults are fully
vaccinated but authorities want to ramp
that up even higher to avoid more
restrictions
at least for those who are vaccinated
president emmanuel macron lambasted the
five million french people still holding
out
in a newspaper interview macron used a
vulgar slang term saying that he wants
to get on the nerves of the unvaccinated
he plans to limit access to public life
to those who can prove they've had the
jab
but macron's comment sparked anger from
political opponents as france gears up
for a presidential election in april
i don't know if it's a political faux
pas or a moral one these comments should
not be made by the president of the
republic who remains the president of
all the french people who must
absolutely avoid creating hysteria
around the debate avoid making
vaccination a referendum for or against
him
parliament is currently discussing a new
and stricter vaccine pass for places
like restaurants bars and cinemas a
heated debate that has now been delayed
as politicians trade insults